Hey, what's up guys?
Chad here from RealLife English and Learn
English with TV Series, with another killer
English lesson for you all based on a scene
from the cool TV show, Two and a Half Men.
Or, as we say in connected speech, 'too-wuh-nah'
half men.
That's your first pronunciation lesson for
today.
So to really make the most out of this scene
I suggest you download the Power Lesson, which
will break down all the new vocabulary, pronunciation,
cultural references, help you really understand
all the jokes, and I think you are going to
really love this lesson.
So if you have any questions, or suggestions
just type them into the comments box below
and we would love to hear about them.
So let's move onto today's awesome lesson.
Awww yeah!!
Alright.
I hope you really enjoyed those first two
parts of the scene with Stu the Tutor, the
pot smoking tutor and ahh let's keep this
learning going by downloading the Power Lesson
and we are going to play you out with the
full scene so really focus on your comprehension,
how much you understand, how much you have
just learned, and there's more to the scene
so if you want to really absorb everything
it's a great way to do that.
Thanks for watching today.
If you guys have any suggestions or questions,
post them in the comments below, we love to
hear from people, and you guys have an amazing
day.
I'll see ya later.